ايمانويل ماكرون يقولوا انه لا يطلب
الصفحه من الجزائريين بعد نشر كتابه
الامير هاري غير مرحبا به في حفل تتويج
والده الحكم بسجن اربعه اطباء في الاردن
بسبب عمليه شفط دهون هذه الاخبار وغيره
نقولها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
في مقابله نشرتها مجله الفرنسيه اكد
الرئيس ايمن والماكرون انه لن يطلب الصفحه
من الجزائريين عن استعمار فرنسا لبلدهم
وفي المقابله التي اجرها معه الكاتب
الجزائري كامل داوود اوضح مكروه انه ليس
مضطرا لطلب الصفحه واضاف هذا ليس الهدف
الكلمه ستقطع كل الروابط على حد تعبيره
مشيرا الى ان اسوء ما يمكن ان يحصل هو ان
نقول نحن نعتذر وكل منا يذهب في سبيل الله
لكنه اعرب عن اماله باي يستقبل نظيره
الجزائري في باريس لمواصله العمل على ملف
الذاكره والمصالحه بين البلدين
يوصلوا الامير هاري تصدر احاديث سوشيال
ميديا بعد طرحه كتابه الجديد في الاسواق
والجديد هذه المره هو ما افدت به مصادر
بريطانيه بانهار لا يكون مرحبا به في حفل
تتويج والدها الملك تشارلز الثالث في شهر
مايو المقبل صحيفه اللي صان اوضحت ان كبار
افراد العائله المالكه قد استوا من فكره
قضاء الوقت مع هاري في الحدث التاريخي
مشيره الى انه من غير الواضح ما اذا كان
الملك سيدعو ابنه الاصغر لحضور حفل
التتويج او ما اذا كان هريسه يقبل الدعوه
بسبب كتابه طبعا هو الذي وجه من خلاله
انتقادات عده للعائله الملكيه
الى الاردن هذه المره حيث اصدرت محكمه صلح
جزاء عمان احكاما بالسجن على اربعه اطباء
تسببوا بوفاه مريضه خلال عمليه شفط دهون
المحكمه قررت حبس طبيب جراح لمده ثلاث
سنوات وطبيب جراح اخر وطبيب مختص بالتخدير
لمده سنه واحده وطبيب تخدير لمده سته اشهر
مشيره الى ان الطبيب الذي اجرى الجراحه لي
س مخ واوضحت ان المدنيين استمروا باجراء
العمليه رغم تدهور حاله الضحيه كما انهم
لم يتدخلوا في الوقت المناسب لايقاف العمل
الجراحي للحين التي دون وفاتها
في خبر امتزج بين الغرابه والطرف اعلنت
السلطات الكنديه اعتقال حمامه بتهمه تهريب
المخدرات في احد السجون السلطات اوضحت انه
تم القبض على الحمامه في ساحه
في كولومبيا البريطانيه نهايه ديسمبر
الماضي مشيره الى ان حقيبه ظهر قماشيه
كانت مربوطه بالحمامه وتحتوي على ماده
الميثم فيتامين المخدره وذكر البيان ان
استخدام الحمام اثار صعوبات في التحقيق
مقارنه بطائرات الدرونز لان دقه درونز
جعلت من السهل تحديد المتلقي المقصود
بالبضائع المهرب لافته الى فتحه التحقيق
في هذه الحادثه الغريبه
وفي خبرنا الاخير توصلت بعثه وكاله ناسا
الى وجود كوكب بحجم الكره الارضيه يدور
حول نجم صغير على بعد نحو 100 سنه ضوئيه
ويحتمل ان يكون عليه مظاهر حياه ناس اوضحت
في بيان ان الكوكب المكتشف حديثا يسمى
تويسه بن هاندرد اي وهو كوكب صخري يساوي
حجمه 95% من حجم كوكب الارض مشيره الى ان
الكوكب الجديد يقع على مسافه من نجم الذي
يدور حوله مما يسمح بوجود الماء على سطحه
ما يعني امكانيه ان يكون صالحا لعيش البشر